All right. Now so just to kind of reinforce this
idea and also to let us think about it in
a slightly different direction, I want you to consider solving
the following quiz. Here's four payoffs that I've put little
boxes around. This one at minus 1, minus 1, this
one at minus 3, 0, and this one at minus
4, minus 4. And the question is, which of these
payoffs can be the average payoff for some joint strategy?
And this is in the repeated game setting, [CROSSTALK]
okay. So what we're imagining is these two players can
coordinate in any way they want. We're not talking
about trying to maximize reward or, or, being Nash or
anything like that. They're just going to execute some,
some pattern of, of strategies over infinite run. We're going to
average the payoffs that the two players get and we'll
say, you know is it possible for them to adopt
a strategy so that the average per time step gets minus 3 for Smooth
and 0 for Curly? Yes or no? So check that box if that's possible. Can it be that
they both get minus one on average? If so, check this box. And can it be
that they both get minus 4 on average?
Check this box. Does that, does that make sense?
>> It does make sense.
>> All right, so I'll give you a chance to think it through and answer it.
>> Okay.